es geht nämlich um folgendes Thema eine
Frau wird vor laufender Kamera beleidigt
in der Hauptrolle Dieter Bohlen das
schauen wir uns noch mal an
ich habe Abitur gemacht und danach
dachte ich mir so was machst du jetzt
ich wollte noch irgendwas cooles machen
Abenteuer erleben das Hauptargument war
das Fame es war keiner nicht Langeweile
gewesen sein tatsächlich einfach die
Kohle oder Fame
Abenteuer cool und Film achso irgendwas
vernünftig also normales gemacht
irgendwie oder hast du nur abi und dann
dich durch Nudeln lassen
für Patricia Blanco ist dieser Satz ganz
klar eine Grenzüberschreitung und Frau
Blanco sie sind auch heute hier sehr
sicher auf Instagram bereits ausführlich
zu dem Thema geäußert sagen Sie uns hier
in die Kamera was würden Sie jetzt
Dieter Bohlen ins Gesicht sagen ja ich
habe das ja schon auf Instagram kund
getan ich hätte ihm einfach gesagt wer
im Glashaus sitzt sollte nicht mit
Steinen werfen weil er hat genau von er
hat ja auch alles wieder gepoppt sage
ich jetzt mal was nicht auf dem Baum kam
in Hamburg so habe ich ihn so also
wahrgenommen und ich finde die Art und
Weise wie er das rüber gebracht hat
fand ich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen so
abwertend und für mich ist das
eigentlich also Dieter Bohlen ich kenne
ihn mal nicht persönlich aber es ist so
ein Grundthema sowieso
es gibt so einen Film ich weiß jetzt
werden alle das soll nicht wohl der sein
aber es gibt schon finden da ist als die
Frauen noch Schwänze hatten sorry das
ist jetzt so ein Film wo ich einfach
sagen muss der Ursprung was er vergisst
ist einfach genauso ein Mädchen kann ihn
halt stürzen von seinem Thron und im
Endeffekt arbeitet er aber genau mit
solchen Themen und er ist eigentlich der
hauptinizator von sowas und er greift
eigentlich jemanden an der nichts Böses
getan hat und diese Emanzipation dass
ich halt dieser Mann ist komplett
prähistorisch das ist für mich Steinzeit
aber das ist ja leider nicht eher nur
sondern da erlebe ich ja tausend solche
Beispiele wieso darf ein Mädel wenn es
Single ist nicht machen was es will
solange ich nicht in einer Beziehung
verheiratet bin oder jemanden schade
darf dieses Mädchen doch sich austoben
was hat es mit dem Abitur zu tun
also ich nenne jetzt hier keine Namen
oder so aber ich bin auch sehr
prähistorisch aufgewachsen ja ich weiß
was es heißt wenn ein Mann ein Macho ist
oder wenn jemand ihren Vater darüber ich
möchte mich da nicht äußern wenn ich da
meistens deswegen wäre es irgendwie
um mich rum als Männer zwei 2023 also da
kann ich jeden Tag zum Beispiel nennen
der Mann darf das einfach also beim Mann
ist es voll cool das ist leider immer
noch so was haben sie dafür Sprüche
gehört oder man darf das voll cool wenn
ich sowas sage ja einfach der Mann wird
natürlich nach oben gelobt wenn er eine
nach der anderen sage ich mal ins
niedere knallt und das Mädchen ist halt
gleich die und es ist heute
noch so oder ähm ja ich kann auch zehn
Bier trinken wieder Mann ich bin halt
der voll Alki und der Mann ist total
geil weil er schafft es weil also sind
lauter so blöde Beispiele aber ich finde
es halt wahnsinnig altmodisch und ich
finde in der heutigen Zeit sollte man
mit sowas nicht mehr arbeiten aber das
Ergebnis hat ja gezeigt wir Frauen sind
im Endeffekt ich finde dass wir stärker
sind also vom ganzen vom ganzen her und
das vergisst ebenso jemand und benutzt
dann so eine Plattform die ihm jetzt
eigentlich zum Verhängnis wird obwohl er
selber so gearbeitet eine Frau zeigt
Führungsstärke ein Mann zeigt
Führungsstärke die Frau gilt dann als
Zicke oder weder anders
auch nicht mehr ich gesagt weiß ich
nicht ist nicht mehr so also
erlebe ich nicht so aber mag sein dass
das noch so ist aber ich wollte noch mal
dazu zu diesem aktuellen Fall zurück ich
verstehe auch RTL nicht in diesem ganzen
ich meine diesen Ausschnitt den wir da
gesehen hat den hat ja nie im im
Fernsehen gegeben sondern nur in dem
vorab Stream ähm er hatte er hat am
Anfang erklärt ja ist uns egal ist halt
so gesagt worden jetzt gibt's
Krisensitzung dann haben Sie Dieter
Bohlen rausgeschmissen vorher aus der
Sendung weil sie gesagt haben nein das
geht gar nicht mehr gegen die Quoten in
den Keller dann haben sie wiedergeholt
und jetzt sprechen
natürlich diese Frau kommt doch Jill
heißt sie glaube ich ne kommt auch nicht
zufällig in diese Sendung und trällerte
ein Mädchen natürlich ist die da rein
platziert worden mit der ganzen
Vorgeschichte und die Vorgeschichte ist
natürlich dass sie an diversen wie sie
ja auch vor Blanco castingshose nicht
castingshose
sich da exponiert hat so und und und und
das wittert jemand wie Bowlen natürlich
auch und weiß natürlich was seine Rolle
da sein soll und spielt damit und also
insofern ist das ein großes show
business mit dem Schwerpunkt Business
nicht damit gerechnet dass dieses
Mädchen das ist ja eben das damit
rechnet so jemand der in dieser Position
glaube ich ist und er hatte er hat damit
auch nicht so gerechnet ihre Reaktion
weil eben sehr stark der der geweint und
alles und das wird natürlich sehr gerne
aufgenommen und ich glaube die halbe
Frauenwelt ist wenn der Bullen alleine
durch den Wald gehen würde würde der
vielleicht das gar nicht überleben weil
17 Frauen im hinterher wird das ist halt
Problem damit wurde nicht gerechnet es
wird schon sehr stark gespielt es kommt
auf die Kandidatin und es gibt auch
welche die hätten sich einschüchtern
lassen hört man einfach so gesagt Björn
hätten das unter den Tisch gekehrt und
das finde ich eben so witzig man darf
nie spielen mit dem Feuer und sagen ich
bin ganz oben ich bin Mann ich darf das
die Quote das ist immer das Problem an
diesen Geschichten die können leider
auch so ausgehen und das hat jetzt die
Riesen Debatte aber ich finde es toll
dass sowas ausgelöst wird weil ich finde
es einfach ihr liebes total oft wenn du
als Frau auch also mir geht's immer so
ich bin ja lauter Mensch ich gebe auch
gern Konter auch in meiner Partnerschaft
in solchen Geschichte
sogar in der Bibel und so zeige ich so
was geht ab ja oder irgendwie Historiker
und ich gerade immer sehr stark am
Prähistoriker und ich bin dann jemand
der dann gerne so ein bisschen austeilt
und das stimmt es kommt einfach bei
Männern nicht gut an ja das ist oder
bist du gleich die immer
du bist ein Mann zwei eine Frau hat sich
ruhig zu verhalten und so die darf das
nicht also ich finde schon sehr witzig
wie viel Sebastian beobachtest du noch
von diesem Historikern die Frau blank
oder schildert in unserer Gesellschaft
ich finde hatte ich die
gesellschaftliche Realität schon doch
deutlich geändert in den vergangenen 20
Jahren aber bei Brunnen ist es ja so ich
habe gelacht über den Spruch das muss
ich sagen das gebe ich zusätzlich noch
mal gesehen habe
nur Werbungen bestellt der kriegt auch
Polen geliefert so und RTL wollte
natürlich diese Art von Sprüchen haben
dass die Frau davon offen war sehr
getroffen hat das ist menschlich
bedauerlich das muss man sagen weiß
natürlich ehrlicherweise auch wenn er in
einer Sonne solche Sendung geht was
einem dazu ähm erwarten hat was mich
ärgert bei RTL ist die geben sich ja so
besonders wow ne die Erklärung anderer
Stelle man darf also nicht mehr von
Geschlechtsumwandlung sprechen sondern
von Geschlechtsangleichung man muss also
dieses innen immer sagen und so damit
den Sternchen und so weiter aber sonst
könnte sich ja irgendwie verletzt fühlen
angeblich und so und dann wird das hier
quasi als ein Teil ihres
Geschäftsmodells so ausgestrahlt das
passt nicht zusammen das ist doppelmora
ich habe selber erlebt in diesen Show
ähm der wird oft Teufel komm raus ich
wurde auch in manchen welche wirklich
animierte du musst jetzt stumm machen du
musst dies also die wollen natürlich
immer diese Quote aber das ist eben
diese Schere Menschen ist es Moral echt
mal es gibt Leute die packen es halt
nicht die bewerben sich zwar da dieses
Mädchen du füllst ja bei diesen DSDS von
Zettel aus dann lesen die sich das
natürlich durch und wenn die natürlich
schreibe ich habe bei Temptation Island
mitgemacht das ist für ihn klar geil ja
und dann erzähl die noch was von Abi
dann macht er gleich so einen Film geil
die Kombi ist ja der Hammer aber ich
finde die Art und Weise man kann sie
auch anders reden hätte er so ein
bisschen netter gemacht dann hättest
sogar so ausgesehen wie ein Vater der
mit seiner Tochter redet der sagt hey du
hast Arian alles und jetzt gehst du in
so blöde dating Shows willst du nicht
was anders machen das hätte ich noch
witzig gefunden aber das hat immer sowas
ein bisschen diese Tonlage so abwerten
quasi also so ist das Showgeschäft
es ist nicht so einfach unsere Show ist
zu Ende wir danke Ihnen ganz herzlich
fürs zusehen vielen herzlichen Dank an
meine Gäste ich freue mich aufs nächste
Mal